today's speaker is Robert heimer he's a
professor here
actor of Sierra's interdisciplinary
research methods core currently his
research focuses focus includes both
field based prevention work and
laboratory investigations of disease
transmission risks the field based work
concentrates on a scientific evaluation
of prevention programs serving drug
users these include syringe exchange
hepatitis vaccination and overdose
prevention the laboratory work
concentrates on the biological
assessment of the risk of syringe
sharing and other drug injection
behaviors that may transmit HIV and
hepatitis C he's done work here in the
US and internationally and today we'll
be focusing on the past present and
future of HIV and AIDS in Russia dr.
heimer thank you for that nice
introduction I haven't even said
anything yet yeah not sure I'll say
anything by the time I'm done we need
you an overview of our work that we've
been doing and some of the analyses that
we've been attempting to do with data
that we've collected in Russian that are
available in Russia from other studies
as well as our own an attempt to paint a
picture of a of an unfolding HIV
epidemic that remains unchecked the
bottom line is the past the present in
the future all pretty bleak you can all
go now but just as an outline of our
talk I'm going to spend a lot of time
talking about the emergence of drug use
and drug use patterns in Russia you know
it's so that you have a better
understanding of the situation there and
what it is that that makes the epidemic
and Russia kind of different from many
other places part of this big difference
is the difference in drug types that
exist in Russia we'll get into that in
detail we'll explore in even more detail
has one form of the drug played a
special role in the expansion of the
epidemic
in Russia when I'm done with that have
confused you enough there will focus
more on the work that we've done in the
city of st. Petersburg and look at the
possibility probability of this epidemic
expanding from one who is concentrated
in injection drug users to the general
population a thing that the Russian
government wants to ignore despite its
increasing likelihood so couple
definitions just so we set the table for
this phrasal excuse i don't know if any
of you get it in your any of your you
know eph classes but the word is sin
demic and sin demic is coined over the
last couple years and it means the
concentration of two or more diseases or
health conditions in which there's an
interaction between them that makes each
of them worse and that and that move
together as a complex in this case we're
talking about this endemic of sin demic
drug use and addiction HIV hepatitis
tuberculosis sexually transmitted
diseases at the end of the talk will
begin to get into the subject of bridge
populations and that's the group of
individuals that are needed to move the
epidemic from the high-risk group of
draw in the case of Russia drug users
into the more general population and
another term that I'm will introduce in
this talk is the force of infection and
that's the rate at which susceptible
individuals become infected by a
pathogen or the rate at which
susceptible groups of individuals become
infected now thus endemics in Russia
really began with an epidemic of drug
addiction in the early 1990s the
parallels to the United States here are
interesting because prior to Russia's
you know Afghan war that ran for a
decade a little longer a little shorter
now than our current Afghan will
the abuse of opioids and stimulant drugs
was was uncommon but it grew in the
1990s with the fall of the Soviet Union
with the opening of borders with the
collapse of the Soviet state with the
anarchy that existed in in many parts of
Russia that coincided with the fall of
communism in attempt to control this the
federal government as it was resent
realizing its control introduced a
federal or narcotic means and
psychotropic substances now this had the
negative effect of making a drug
addiction actually a crime and at the
same time discourage prevention programs
harm reduction programs such as needle
exchange or access to syringes and
actually banned substitution therapy
which is the only sort of evidence-based
form of effective treatment for opiate
addiction and the o people were talking
about mostly in Russia will be heroin
and in you know as this was happening
Russian cities works were experiencing
many of the Russian cities especially
those with any money were experiencing
expanding heroin markets as young and
disaffected people started using drugs
that were different from the drugs that
their parents use which was mostly vodka
they went on and decided well you know
let's try other cool drugs like you know
heroin and there is there was a heroin
chic in Russia just like there was in
the United States about that time and
the epidemics that are associated with
with with injection drug use HIV
hepatitis C fatal opiate overdose among
drug users began in the late 1990s and
HIV was first noticed in the westernmost
Russian city of Kaliningrad in the
summer of nineteen ninety six so we're
not talking about an epidemic that's
about 14 years old
15 years old heroin addiction is a huge
problem in Russia there are an estimated
approximately two million heroin
injectors in Russia out of a population
of 145 million that means more than one
percent of the population you know has a
history of injecting heroin in addition
to commercial heroin which you could for
instance find on the street corner is
about six or seven blocks from here if
you knew it look Russia Russian drug
users also manufactured heroin at home a
substance they call shania which is the
Russian word for black and you'll see
why in a bit why it's called black they
also manufacture their own stimulants
psychostimulants methamphetamine and
meth katha gnome these are common in
some locations in Russia but not not
everywhere drug availability and Russia
varies widely but generally speaking the
once a commercial heroin market comes to
town it stays there it doesn't disappear
most places start off with the homemade
drugs and then move on to heroin and the
only sort of exceptions we've seen to
this is there have been heroin shortages
from time to time in Russia most notably
at when the Taliban clamped down on
heroin an opiate production in
Afghanistan and for the year after that
at the start of Afghan warm now there
are some studies in some single
locations in Russia that have linked
homemade drug use to increased HIV
prevalence but those are more
associations than any kind of causative
thing so we don't know really what to
make of that kind of association but
just so you understand how this homemade
drug is you know is prepared notice the
clock on the left it's a few minutes
after eleven when this production was
started you take poppies you grind them
up you alkalinize some some water using
by adding sodium bicarbonate and you
cook the poppies in this alcohol and
water to it to extract from it the
alkaloids that include morphine codeine
papaverine and some other things but
you're of course most interested in
morphine which becomes heroin at the end
the mixture is boiled and filtered and
then the opiate alkaloids are are found
in this liquid used poppies can be safe
for a second extraction we'll talk about
that in a bit to the alkaloids are then
back extracted into an organic solvent
that doesn't mix with water and extract
it again out of out of this organic
solvent into an acid solution usually
sulfuric guess it's pretty intense and
serious stuff but all of these things
serve to reduce the volume of liquid
which is further reduced by boiling off
the acidic solution and you can see this
stuff in the bottom of a white enamel
pot is pretty black hence the name tryn
ayah now you have an opiate alkaloid
mostly morphine it's reacted with acetic
anhydride to yield diacetyl morphine
which is also known as heroin and you
can still see it's pretty ugly in black
the mixture is again reduced by boiling
and being filtered now the starting
material for this can be as I showed in
these pictures ground up poppies but it
can also be opium gum which is the SAP
of the poppy pod rather than the
positive cells and you know if you had
in your hands some opium poppies the gum
from that would be eleven percent
morphine by weight but many of the
Russians don't have access to you know
papaver somniferum the opium poppy they
have the ornamental poppies that they
grabbed from the fields I was talking to
a Russian friend of mine who said his
parents used to grow poppies by their
Dodger their summer home but they
stopped doing it because the drug users
would come by and steal all the poppies
now sometimes if you especially if you
start with the poppies themselves and
not the opium gum you end up with a
solution that contains lots of
microfibers and you don't really want to
be injecting those microfibers and you
don't really get away you don't really
get rid of them by filtering these
things to a towel but what some Russians
do is try to clarify if you will they're
a poppy solution at some stage by adding
blood and having the blood curdle this
is actually a classic French cooking
technique if you if you want to clarify
abu jaan what you would do is make your
stock and leave it on the stove and then
you'd make a raft that contains vet
chopped up vegetables and egg white /
albumin you bring it to a boil of
albumin curdles it all rises to the top
you skim it all off and you get a
beautiful clear blue yonder well a
Russian isn't going to waste an egg on
this process so and of course they have
syringes and access to another source of
albumin cero element in their blood so
they take their blood and they put it in
and they boil it up and they then can
can skim off this stuff our filter it
away and they end up with a clearer
solution and you'll see a picture of it
in the last line of the series on making
china and when you do that it looks a
sort of a brownish yellow color rather
than black if you're making your heroin
from non opium poppies it's going to be
very weak you're gonna get a little bit
of opioid buzz which you might get from
some codeine some morphine some heroin
that you've got that mixed but is going
to be low concentration and so what
Russian drug users do to get that
specifically heroin nod the sleepy
feeling you've rather than euphoria is
to add an estimate on how many of you
take an histamine sometimes for your
cold and find it it makes you drowsy
well if you inject it it makes you very
drowsy and so the Russians used is
strong and histamine demetriou which is
very often added to their opiate mix to
give them
the satisfaction of a drug that actually
sort of market eise's them so there's
the Chennai in the syringe when it was
done you can see this took about two two
and a half hours to make the final
product is ready to be injected
alternatively you can store this inside
syringes for later use or it can be sold
and it's almost invariably sold as a
liquid you're not going to dry this down
and the storage often occurs inside of
syringes and one of the things that
people have considered as a possible
route for HIV transmission is that if
this stuff is stored inside of a
contaminated syringe and you give that
syringe or sell that syringe full of
drug to somebody else you can transmit
the virus possibly now the HIV epidemic
in Russia takes on this interesting
characteristic that prior to 1995-96 I
guess almost all the cases of HIV
infection the first thousand cases
detected in Russia and mind you this is
HIV infection not AIDS people hadn't
been sick long enough for many of these
people to get AIDS this is HIV detection
by serology most of the cases were
either sexual among heterosexuals men
with sex with men or hospital based and
those are camiel infections however 1996
there was a dramatic and significant
change where all of a sudden most of the
contributors to the thousand new
infections or eleven hundred new
infections identified in that year alone
who are among injection drug users
and ever since then the epidemic has
continued to expand some very rapid
increases at the beginning of the last
decade with eighty thousand or so new
cases detected in 2001 and the funny
thing is that you know for a while it
looks as though the epidemic was
declining but then again late in the
last decade it shot up again in fact
there were 65 nearly 60,000 cases
diagnosed in in 2009 probably as many
cases will be finally will be diagnosed
again in this year 2010 so this is an
epidemic that's far from under control
it's an epidemic that is concentrated
overwhelmingly in injection drug users
at least three-quarters of the cases are
in people who have a history of
injection drug youth a lot of cases are
still of unknown origin or unknown
etiology unattributable to one of these
risk categories so many of those people
may even be also be injection drug users
who successfully hidden their injection
drug use status from the Russian
government but the thing about Russia is
Russia Russians think of themselves as
unique and so even though this epidemic
growth looks like the epidemic that's
occurred in many places among injection
drug users with a rapid increase in HIV
high prevalence of HIV in drug users
Russia has to invoke unusual causes it's
just something the Russians do we're
different from everybody else therefore
what caused our epidemic has to be
different and miss anecdotal reporting
of blood inside syringes and blood being
used during homemade heroin preparation
led to the speculation that contaminated
drugs themselves may be fundamental to
the epidemic it's not the syringes the
drugs are contaminated and if the drugs
are contaminated and it doesn't matter
whether or not we give out clean
syringes we're not going to prevent the
epidemic from being transmitted
therefore we don't need needle exchange
which is effectively curtail the
epidemic in many other parts of the
world so the Russians say you know screw
it 22 harm reduction screw it to need
looking
we don't need it it's not going to
change our epidemic we need to focus on
healthy lifestyle so that people don't
use drugs and we were curious whether or
not this belief that it's the homemade
drugs that caused the epidemic was
really true or not so we wanted to test
whether or not homemade drugs were
capable of carrying the virus and
transmitting the virus from person to
person was it actually contaminated
drugs that's hypothesis one hypothesis
two is that it may not be the drugs
themselves but certain behavioral
features of homemade drug users you see
this is done in people's kitchens it
takes a while to very social practice
maybe this leads to excessive Sir Ian
sharing people hanging around could
these behavioral features particular to
homemade drug use that were once common
throughout Russia you know explain the
the rapid epidemic rather than more
traditional reasons why epidemic spread
among drug users which is lack of access
to clean syringes so does you know so
the question is how does HIV enter the
chernaya well it comes in this blood
that people may be using and adding to
you know to help purify their drugs if
the person adding blood is HIV positive
than HIV is added can also enter the
drugs during storage if the drug is
stored in a syringe that was previously
used by someone with HIV positive then
that drug solution might have some HIV
floating around in it so we're going to
test both does virus survive during
manufacture or during storage and we did
this by replicating turn on manufacture
in our laboratory based on ethnographic
observations still photography videos we
elaborate
in a protocol for a prototypical shania
production and we did this in the lab we
got a license from the US Drug
Enforcement Administration that allowed
us to actually make heroin here on
campus don't try this in your dorm room
infected blood was then prepared to
contained HIV titers common among
infected people to see if we could
recover virus from from these chernaya
preparations as a preliminary control
experiment we wanted to be sure that the
Chennai itself didn't reduce HIV when it
was added to HIV replication when added
to the culture so we first mixed target
cells in hiv-infected blood then added
the tren aya we saw no diminution in
this case of of HIV replication so the
chernaya diluted as it was in our tissue
culture combination of cells virus and
shania we got we got five viral
propagation so we had a working system
and then we what meant went and made the
Trillia with blood and we did this 11
times and never could we propagate and
recover HIV from the chernaya so this is
actually not a surprising result you
know you saw how the preparation was
made you saw there were you know caustic
chemicals being used you saw there was
heating and boiling and evaporation all
of which is toxic to the virus no
surprise that these that the despite the
belief in some quarters that the drugs
come contaminated because people use
blood that's as we say fiction and but
the question is could the syringes in
which in which the drug was routinely
stored transmit the virus or result in
in the survival of virus that could be
transmitted when that solution is then
injected into someone who's HIV negative
so what we did was we load of the
syringes with about the amount of
lud that might remain in a in a syringe
with a detachable needle and then just
as a control we flush those syringes
with saline and introduced it into our
culture system and we could recover a
virus from every syringe that was
manhandled in this way however when we
fill the syringe with art renea solution
and then introduce that into culture we
found about an eighty percent reduction
in viability or recovery of HIV from the
vibe from the syringes suggesting that
the chernaya or something in the mix
from the poppies or the chemicals are in
fact toxic under the circumstances in
which teacher nya and the virus are
mixed first instead of the chernaya
being added at the end in culture now I
mentioned to you that the poppies can be
saved and reused again but in the case
when this happens the yield of morphine
alkaloids will be greatly reduced so
reacts tracting these use poppies can
help us determine whether the inhibition
that we're seeing results from the
chemicals or something from the poppies
and what we found was in fact with the
return of viability from syringes in the
second preparation of Sarnia that it's
actually probably something in the
poppies themselves that's inhibiting rep
you know the ability of virus to to
reproduce in culture to propagate and
culture so it isn't the chemicals it
seems to be the poppies now you might
think well isn't this wouldn't this be a
wonderfully effective anti HIV
medication but imagine that this is a
mix of twenty microliters of blood and
about two mils of solution I just
quickly do the math and figure out that
in order to inactivate HIV in your blood
you'd need about gallons and gallons
maybe dozens of gallons or hundreds of
gallons of chernaya and there's no way
you're going to get that into your blood
anyway so it's not going to work as an
anti-hiv medication it might be
interesting to try to figure out what
exactly it is in the poppies that
that resulted in lower viability but
that's not something that I'm have the
skills in my laboratory to do or any
interest in trying to figure out so does
if it's not the drugs is it homemade
practices I'll give you the skinny on
this there's no there were no there's no
evidence that from our studies in in 11
Russian cities that we where we
collected data throughout Russia in 2003
2005 that behaviors of people who inject
homemade drugs currently or initiated
their drug use with homemade drugs are
higher risk than people who use
commercial heroin so it isn't the
behaviors it isn't the drugs themselves
that are responsible for the rapid
proliferation of HIV in many Russian
cities so since we couldn't confirm
either hypothesis what is the
explanation for why HIV is increased so
markedly in some cities and not in
others and what we ended up concluding
is that it's not the Chennai at all
actually it's the conversion to
commercial heroin and to make this
determination we analyzed several
sources of data looking at an ecological
data on HIV prevalence from entire
regions that's data set one data set 2
is data set from this liquid drug study
that we did in 11 cities and data set 3
it's from a more recent
second-generation surveillance at eight
Russian cities and we use what's called
the preponderance of information
approaches these are all sort of
correlations rather than rather than
conclusive proofs so here's the here's
the ecological data and what you can see
is for a bunch of about 25 26 cities
here's HIV prevalence from low to high
ranking in terms of high prevalence so
we've got some cities that are all the
way at the top of HIV prevalence we've
got some cities that are nearly all the
way at the bottom
among the 90-89 administrative districts
in Russia and what you can see is that
low prevalence is associated pretty
strongly with homemade drugs and high
prevalence is associated with commercial
drugs with a couple of exceptions that
are worth discussing yaroslavl where
commercial heroin has predominated for a
decade now it's got low prevalence one
of the reasons for this is the prior to
the introduction of commercial heroin in
in yaroslavl there was a harm reduction
program that introduced peer to peer
education about safe injection and about
access and a subsequent program to allow
people to go to pharmacies and get clean
syringes this seems to have made a
difference in keeping the epidemic in
Yaroslavl from ever occurring chop I
asked is interesting it's a small city
of about 70,000 people in the same
province samara oblast s tolyatti a city
of 1.1 million remember these data are
at the level of the province so the fact
that there's no HIV that we could detect
in in in the drug users we interviewed
in chop I asked I would have no effect
on HIV prevalence in this Oblast we're
in a city like tolyatti by 2002 more
than fifty percent of drug users were
already HIV positive so this anomaly is
one that's just a dep ideological oddity
and due to the difference between
understanding things at the level of the
city versus the level of the province
but this is an ecological approach it's
HIV prevalence for the entire population
not just of people who inject drugs
remember we're talking about there
between region and city so the second
drug study this liquid drug study that
we did in 11 cities again found a very
strong correlation between the
percentage of people who report you
commercial heroin in the last 30 days
and HIV positivity in the population now
the problem with this study and why it's
not completely conclusive is that
hiv-positive is not done by serological
testing but by self-report and
self-report is you know as work we've
shown in st. Petersburg can be
notoriously inaccurate so the best study
in terms of looking at this would be our
the second-generation surveillance which
was done in 88 Russian cities and what
we found again however is a fairly
strong correlation between high levels
of commercial heroin use and high HIV
prevalence with a couple of exceptions
the one exception being Arielle but
what's interesting about Arielle is
there's a large percentage of people who
inject stimulants which could result in
unsafe needle practices and I guess the
other one no that's about it oh and
relatively low HIV prevalence in
Aboriginal chelny nubber asianet chelny
is a city in the autonomous Republic of
Pakistan Pakistan also began HIV
prevention work targeted to drug users
with needle exchange and peer drug user
education back about 2,000 so that may
help to explain why prevalences remained
low even though everybody injects
heroine the commercial form
the weakness of this really is that the
major weakness is that there really are
no historical data about when the
transitions the commercial heroine
occurred and whether or not that
transition is directly linked to
increasing prevalence tried when I was
in Russia to get these data which are so
look at in cat entry into drug treatment
into detoxification programs which is
the only form of drug treatment they
have and get data about as a marker for
when the market changed from homemade to
commercial heroin to get some interview
data from local police about when these
things that happen and to get data about
increasing AIDS cases from the local Aid
Center many of this is publicly of
supposedly publicly available data but
publicly available data are not really
publicly available to pay to get them
and the the fellowship that I was on
didn't allow me to have money to pay
people so I got a little bit of the data
which seemed to support the fact that
when heroin comes to town the number of
drug users go up which could of course
be the at the root of why you're seeing
increasing prevalence is that not that
one drug is more likely to transmit the
virus than the other but rather than
just there was a larger group of people
who can who are in the at risk pool so
that's it for sort of the history the
past you know we have been working in
st. Petersburg now since 2000 we've
conducted a large number of studies a
couple of drug cohorts of drug users
have been followed we've estimated HIV
incidence and it's it's always very high
and HIV prevalence in st. Petersburg
keeps going up in the course of the
studies that have been done over the
past 12 years you know HIV prevalence is
gone from 2% in drug users on a
continuously upward climb till now more
than half of the draw
users in st. Petersburg are hiv-positive
not a pretty picture and it's a find it
those of us who work there finding very
frustrating that all this work we do in
documenting the epidemic has no very
little influence on getting the
government to change what it does that's
different that's a whole different talk
on but we in all most recent study which
we could finished in Milan I guess our
second two most recent study that we did
with drug users that we concluded in
2008 we measured incidents in
cross-sectional studies now you're not
really supposed to do this if you really
want to measure incidents you're
supposed to run you know longitudinal
studies where you get data before and
then you get there after when you look
at the number of people who serial
convert over time the only problem with
this is that well three problems one is
they're very expensive too in some cases
you have high loss to follow-up which
may not be a random and therefore may
influence your data and the third thing
is that sometimes being in a
longitudinal study itself seems to be an
intervention that reduces incidents so
for instance the alive cohort in
Baltimore which is study drug users for
now 20 years found high incidents in the
first year and people were seen
repeatedly you know every six months
over the over these years of this study
high incidence in year one and then all
sudden incidents bottoms out and stays
low why probably because part of the
thing that you can't want to do
ethically as part of your as part of
your interaction with a high-risk
population is to give them ways in which
they can reduce their risk and that
happens so in some ways even though
you're not supposed to get incidents
from cross-sectional studies if you have
adequate methods for trying to estimate
incidence they may be a true reflection
of the incidents in your in your
community at least that's what we like
to believe and we have
two measures of incidence one was we
built into our study a retrospective
cohort we asked people had they been
previously tested and when they
previewed been previously tested when
their last negative test was and so we
had a group of people who we knew when
they were last tested some of them
stayed negative throughout the whole
study some of them became infected
between the last time they were tested
and the time they were tested in our
study we are betrayal ESET the midpoint
between when they were last tested and
when they were tested in the study as
when they got infected and and built
this cohort the second way is this we
try to use the serological method called
b.ed testing which attempts to identify
those individuals who are recently
infected and this testing takes into
account all the people who are positive
from the study retests them to detect
those people who are likely to have a
recent infection so first the
retrospective cohort in our study we had
322 people who were disease-free
reported being HIV negative at their
last test 65 of them at acquired disease
incidence rate of 14.1 percent 14.1
400-person years that is a phenomenally
high incidence rate for HIV that happens
at the beginning of many HIV epidemics
among drug users in locations it's very
unusual to find that high and incidents
10 years into it into the epidemic in
any place it really suggests incredible
neglect on the part of the public health
sector when we use the B EDSA we
actually found that
I need a higher incidence rate of twenty
twenty percent per year there we know
that the b.ed overestimates incidents it
doesn't almost every time it's been
applied but these give us a range
between say fourteen and twenty percent
incidents per year so somewhere between
one in every seven and one in every five
drug users who was HIV negative last
year is HIV positive this year so who
are these injectors you know they're
young they're most are 18 to 35 median
age was 29 in our study thirty percent
were women a third are fully employed
many are in school ten percent have a
university education russia has a
two-tier educational system in which
people after high school either stopped
going to school or they go to university
they go to a couple years of training
pre-university give nauseum education
then go on to university or or go into
some sort of vocational training and
another twenty-five percent had
vocational training the rest stop school
after the age of 16 but it's interesting
fifty-five percent of them live with
their parents and unlike what we think
of as prototypical or classical drug
users very few were engaged in illegal
activity these are not reprobates these
are not social deviance these are just
people who happen to have used drugs
many of whom have become addicted to
their their opiate use as a result of
injecting so the force of infection in
st. petersburg remains drug users to
this day we could control the epidemic
if we would provide antiretroviral
therapy to drug users and in fact latest
studies from Europe the Americas and
Africa all agree that by reducing
individual
you know level viral load transmission
can probably be reduced the Russian Aid
Center refuses to provide antiretroviral
drugs to active drug users they have to
be clean for six months if they're put
on antiretroviral drugs and they revert
to drug use their taken off their their
medications clearly nothing is being
done to blunt the force of infection in
st. Petersburg in fact this has reached
a point that you're now seeing the
epidemic spread from drug use the core
drug using population of injectors to
the broader population and this occurs
you know through sexual bridges now of
course injectors can infect each other
by either shared syringes or by unsafe
sex but if they have unsafe sex they can
transmit the virus to their sex partners
who in turn can transmit the virus to
other non injectors and what we saw is
that this is not an uncommon possibility
in st. Petersburg eighty-four percent of
the drug users we interviewed were
sexually active and you know two out of
five of their partners they knew not to
be drug users so there's a large
population of non drug users having sex
with drug users forty-six percent of the
non drug users of potential bridges to
the general population and that is to
say the non drug users were themselves
having sex with other non drug users
forty-one percent of these partnerships
with potential bridges between ID use
and non I to use and between non I to
use who were sex partners have ideas and
non ideas who are not sex partners of I
to use were unprotected
fifteen percent of the non-id you sex
partners were already hiv-positive so
we're already seeing a great deal of
transmission sexual transmission from
drug users to non drug-using sex
partners and we estimate that at least
one quarter of all heterosexual
transmission is in in st. Petersburg is
from ID nidu to a non IDU sex partner
and not within the drug using populated
within the drug using population would
you know drug user to drug user or non
drug user to non drug user so here's
what the data look like on this on this
chart those are the sex partners the sex
partners were continuing to have sex
with other non injectors and if you try
to estimate prevalence in the general
population from these data what we could
determine was that not going through all
these numbers the you know if there are
1.5 million people between the ages of
18 and 45 the population is most at risk
for contracting HIV than the population
in the general prevalence even excluding
injectors is very close to one percent
these are data from only as far as three
years ago because this epidemic has gone
unchecked one estimate or one can
estimate that this number is is
increasing and is approaching that
threshold of two percent of the general
population at which the epidemic is
considered to be no longer a
concentrated epidemic in a high-risk
population but rather a generalized HIV
epidemic now that this previous
estimation is based on a simple back
calculation looking at the data on who
was infected
how many them were non injectors sex
rates among this population how many
cases would be tested and not tested we
can also model the data if we want using
mathematical modeling and these give us
very similar results the estimated
prevalence is about point eight percent
again approaching that one percent level
and this is in 2006 we're in the process
actually as we speak I believe one of
our faculty members is enroute to
Britain to start trying to put together
a stochastic model of HIV prevalence and
transmission in the general population
based on the data we collected in the
study I hope that he and his British
colleagues will have some something to
present about this to take these data
out to see where the epidemic is heading
now so that we can report these back to
the to the Russian government the local
government in the hopes of getting them
to finally do something so where is the
epidemic heading it's still concentrated
in in drug users certainly in st.
Petersburg we're seeing increasing
prevalence among drug injectors in a
number of Siberian cities over the last
couple of years so the epidemic
continues to spread uncontrolled in drug
users it's spreading in the heterosexual
population in some cities not just
saying Petersburg adult prevalence is
approaching 2% Russia as I said Russia
is unique russia may be the first
country in the glue on the globe to
experience a generalized epidemic of HIV
that originated among injectors no other
country has seen that happen everywhere
else where you've seen a generalized
epidemic sub-saharan Africa it's
heterosexual transmission
Thailand was on the verge of one was
completely controlled by controlling
sexual transmission rush is going to be
unique and because they're doing nothing
unlike many of the surrounding countries
to control addiction we are really going
to see over the next couple of years
whether or not this epidemic will will
be generalized as I say what's Russia
doing not much the Russian government
fails to conduct proper surveillance to
understand the scope of the epidemic as
an example in st. Petersburg I asked
them well how many drug users do you
think you have and they say well we got
ten thousand registered drug users we
must have 10,000 drug users and I say
but wait a second you have 40,000 HIV
infections seventy-seven percent of
those are in people who injected drugs
that's more than 30,000 drug users how
can you say you only have ten thousand
drug users statistics say we only have
ten thousand drug users so we estimated
and just published last year are our
findings on what we estimate to be the
number of drug users injection drug
users in st. Petersburg in us
eighty-three thousand plus or minus
twelve thousand clearly almost an order
of magnitude difference from the city
estimates but the city people cling to
what their day to tell them everything
else is is irrelevant they the russian
federal government spends less on HIV
prevention than the state of Connecticut
spends on HIV prevention and a leaf is
just nodding his head in disbelief that
anybody could spend less than
Connecticut but in fact for a population
of one hundred and forty some odd
million people Russia spends less than
Connecticut at 3.1 only 3.6 million
people's man
despite the fact that their epidemic is
out of control in our epidemic isn't
Russia refuses the federal government
refuses adamantly refuses repeatedly
aggressively refuses to accept
internationally accepted methods of
targeted HIV prevention they refuse to
believe that what's worked everywhere
else in the world the control the
epidemic and drug users will work in
their country their HIV epidemic and
even more they refuse to accept and even
actively prohibit evidence-based
treatments for those people who have
heroin addiction that's at the core of
their HIV epidemic methadone
buprenorphine are illegal you cannot
treat heroin addiction with an opiate
which is the only proven way of keeping
people from using illegal drugs illegal
opiates in any effective and consistent
and long long-term method instead Russia
uses a 10-day detoxification you know
which is sort of the equivalent you know
considering that addiction is a chronic
disease that is caused by long-term
changes in the brain it's like you're
diagnosed with type 1 diabetes you go to
the hospital they stabilize your blood
sugar with insulin they release you 10
days later and say oh by the way we like
you can't get any more insulin it no
sense unless you begin to understand
that the Russian approach to
unacceptable behavior is really one
based on ostracizing social deviance
and in many ways there are a large
proportion of people in the Russian
government in the Russian Orthodox
Church who all believe that there's no
point in doing anything for drug users
you know in a sense we will passively
let them die despite all the evidence
that you can amass that says well you're
not stopping the epidemic from spreading
outside the drug using population you
are facing a demographic bottleneck you
know your population is 140 some million
people and it's actually shrinking daily
your country is getting less populated
your fertility rate is the second lowest
in the world below but you know only
Italy has a lower rate of fertility than
Russia so you're going to throw away 1
million two million of your citizens
simply because they had the bad fortune
to become addicted to drugs but you know
theatre to achieve the who is considered
the third great of the three Russian
Romantic poets after lermontov and
Pushkin said Russia cannot be understood
by the mind and I think that's the
bottom line in a sense that we have to
find in a sense non-rational ways of dis
coercing with kind of it's kind of like
dealing with Republicans and gun control
it's something I mean you have to have
to do it's something I still believe can
be done but it is something that has its
great frustrations which is probably why
I drink a lot of vodka thank you yeah
you